[Musique]
c'est une excellente question
parce que bon de vous avoir vu le profil
de certains élus en effet on peut se
demander qui votent pour pouvoir voter
aux élections municipales c'est très
simple il suffit de remplir quatre
critères avoir la nationalité française
ou celle d'un des 27 ou 28 pays membres
de l'union européenne
et oui avec le break 6 penser plus trop
combien en est un 26 ennemis disons à
côté de cela il faut jouir de ses droits
civils et politiques être majeur et
surtout être inscrit sur les listes
électorales
mais pas n'importe lesquels vous avez
deux possibilités soit vous vous
inscrivez sur les listes électorales de
la ville de votre domicile principal
soit sur celle de la commune nouveau
payer des impôts locaux depuis au moins
deux ans par exemple dans la ville de
votre société si vous êtes chef
d'entreprise ou de votre résidence
secondaire si vous êtes pt 2 est moins
chanceux héritiers pour moi par exemple
l'ajout petites résidences secondaires
et scott adam lot-et-garonne mais je
peux me présenter dans sa commune pour
devenir le maire de 154 habitants et 300
moutons
d'ailleurs pour tout vous dire c'est sur
ces derniers que je compte pour être élu
donc pas de panique pour nous les jeunes
beaux gosses des moins de 26 ans 1 il ya
une petite exception
on peut s'inscrire dans la commune de
papa maman même si on y vit plus
vraiment encore une bonne occase pour
venir squatter manger une tarte aux
pommes le dimanche midi ça on vous
inscrire sur les listes électorales vous
avez jusqu'au 7 février 2000 fin vous
pouvez le faire en mairie par courrier
en joignant un formulaire cerfa et les
pièces justificatives ou en ligne sur le
site service public.fr si vous avez la
flemme de vous déplacer où vous n'avez
pas envie de voir la tronche d'isabelle
la soeur du beau frère du cousin votre
oncle que vous avez vu deux fois et qui
travaille à la mairie
notez que quelques retardataires sont
autorisés à s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales
une fois les délais dépassés mais pas
n'importe qui un parmi eux les personnes
qui obtiennent la nationalité française
ou leurs 18 ans en cours de route
moralité dépêchez-vous à obtenir vos 18
ans c
sur ce je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine un nouvel épisode en
attendant n'oubliez pas de me poser vos
questions à l'adresse ci dessous
allez ciao